hello everyone it's seven o'clock you're
watching Sky News breakfast the
revelations just keep on coming Prince
Harry says he wants to reconcile with
his family despite making a stream of
Sensational claims in his new Memoir
laying bare the depth of the rift with
his brother and the Royals
well Sky News has obtained a copy of the
book accidentally put on sale in Spain
and read it cover to cover we'll bring
you analysis of the key Revelations
including how he sought a fresh
investigation into his mother's death
and the security questions raised by
sharing the number of people he killed
while serving in Afghanistan
Friday the 6th of January
beloved brother and arch nemesis the
Royal Rift laid bear Sky News obtains a
copy of Prince Harry's memoir
I talk about the red mess that I had for
so many years and I saw this Red Mist in
him he wanted me to to head him back but
I chose not to
teenage drug use Afghanistan and his
fight for justice for Diana just some of
the previously unheard Revelations
I'll have the latest from Buckingham
Palace and what it all means for the
Royals who for now are staying silent
and I'll have the latest from Ukraine
where president zielinski has rejected a
Russian call for a 36-hour ceasefire to
Mark Orthodox Christmas
rail passengers face another day of
disruption as train workers stage
refreshed 48-hour walkout with only one
in five Services running
in the Premier League Manchester City
put the pressure back on Arsenal with a
one-nil win against Chelsea
trust your guard I'll speak to the
scientists and author Tim Spector about
how we should actually be what we should
actually be doing to keep our bodies
healthy
in the weather most places look mild and
fine today but there'll be some glossary
showers around mainly over Scotland
where early severe Gales are possible in
the North
[Music]
hello good morning and welcome to Sky
News breakfast now Prince Harry has
insisted that he wants to reconcile with
his family after describing his brother
as his arch nemesis in a jaw-dropping
memoir exposing just how fractured his
relationship is with the Royal Family
well Sky News has read the entire book
spare which was accidentally put on sale
briefly in Spain for its release date
next week well in the Memoir Prince
Harry makes a series of devastating
Revelations including how he urged his
father not to marry Camilla how he was
told about Diana's death and even
replicated his mother's final journey in
Paris
but some of his claims have prompted
renewed questions about security after
Prince Harry shared details of his
military record while serving in
Afghanistan
so let's take a look at some of the key
Revelations Harry says that he wanted
the investigation into the death of his
mother Princess Diana to be reopened and
for more people to be held accountable
he also says that he and Prince William
asked their father King Charles not to
marry Camilla
writing about his time serving in
Afghanistan Harry says he killed 25
Taliban fighters
he also talks about his teenage drug use
saying he used cocaine for the first
time when he was 17.
amongst the most Sensational claims is
of an alleged physical confrontation
with William Harry says his brother
knocked him to the floor in 2019.
and Harry says when his father called
him about the Queen's ill health in
September the soon-to-be King told him
that Megan wasn't welcome at Balmoral
her in agripports
they were billed as The Fab Four to
revolutionize the monarchy together but
any hope of that is now firmly gone
there's damning allegations more
personal than ever are in black and
white Sky News has read Prince Harry's
entire new memoir
among the Cascade of Bombshells it
reveals he asked for a fresh
investigation into his mother's death
which was rejected ten years after her
death he chose to replicate her journey
that night in Paris by asking a driver
to take him through the same tunnel the
105 kilometers per hour I think what
we're seeing here is a wounded
individual I mean this is a man who
hasn't had an easy life
um you know he lost his mother that that
wounded him and he's weaponized that
wound
um in he's in a bubble and he's
surrounded by people telling him what he
needs to do and surrounded by people who
are obviously earning money on the back
of what he's doing as well
the book was on sale in Spain for a few
hours by mistake it includes how he
didn't want his father King Charles to
marry Camilla Willie and I promised our
father that we would welcome Camilla to
the family the only thing we asked for
in return was that he didn't marry her
you don't need to get married again we
asked him
they agreed on that but it's the
differences between the two brothers
which has had devastating consequences
with an accusation of a physical
altercation between now two enemies
what was different here was this level
of frustration and you know I talk about
the red mess that I had for so many
years and I saw this Red Mist in him he
wanted me to to head him back but I
chose not to
I want reconciliation but first there
needs to be some accountability the
truth supposedly at the moment has been
there's only one side to this story
right
but there's two sides to every story
this is one of four television
interviews to come after the Oprah
interview like Netflix docu series
the king asked his sons to not make his
final years of misery but this Rift
won't make it easy
ashnaharinag Sky News
well with more on the revelations
contained in the book Skies Katie
Spencer is here with me and we'll also
be talking in just a moment too our
Royal correspondent Laura bundog who's a
Buckingham Palace but Katie to you first
of all and you've got the book there
um it's in Spanish obtained it from
Spain of course and some extraordinary
Revelations within it so what have we
learned about Prince Harry and perhaps
even what insights do we get about why
he's doing this we've had this book for
for less than a day now in Spanish as
you say so the whole process has been
translating it back into English so that
we can work out the exact lines that
this Memoir contains and I have to say
the level of detail that's contained in
this book it is Extreme the revelations
that you have already mentioned today we
talk about
um he talks about his teenage drug
taking being told of his mother's death
and also this physical altercation that
he had with Prince William as well but
also just the level of over sharing in
the extreme that this contains as well
you read this and you end up with
details that you perhaps didn't even
need to know details about how he lost
his virginity details about whether or
not he's been circumcised he comes
across very damaged at times it's a very
sad story obviously because of his
background and what he's been through he
talks about the PTSD that he's
experienced he talks about having
agrophobia and and also just the fact
that he's needed therapy over the years
but also at times he comes across as
being a bit Petty and a bit petulant at
catty even at times he talks about his
brother's hair loss being worse than his
he talks about
um his explanation for wearing the Nazi
uniform to a friend's party within that
apology if you like he also throws his
brother and Kate under the the bus by
saying he told them in advance that he
was going to do this so it does feel a
you question perhaps the advice that he
has been given in terms of how much he
has shared he even goes into details
about uh the the day that he met with
his family when it was announced that
the queen died going into the room and
seeing his grandmother's body so it is
an incredible amount of detail that he
shares here and you do uh Wonder really
what the Fallout will be in terms of his
own mental health clearly he wanted to
be a a
advocate for mental health if you like
as well and encourage people to talk
about these things but you do get the
impression that certainly you wonder
what piece he will find from sharing so
much and some extraordinary Revelations
and and transparency about his time in
Afghanistan as well which is raise some
eyebrows again yes because he he talks
about the the amount of Taliban members
of the Taliban that he has killed he
says uh 25 and that in itself is
somebody that is so concerned about his
family's privacy and protecting his
family if you look at the reaction that
that's caused on Twitter within certain
countries he has effectively if you like
put a Target on his family's back in in
sharing so much so yeah an incredible
amount of detail in here Casey thanks
very much indeed so let's bring in Laura
bondoc who's at Buckingham Palace for us
this morning so Laura some extraordinary
Revelations about himself but also
allegations against his family as well
so how might the palace react
and that's the big question isn't it the
Publishers had always promised this
unflinching honesty but I don't think
any member of the royal family would
have expected the book to go just this
far I mean these Revelations are really
raw Harry is exposing those very private
moments these personal conversations in
great details look for now we've had no
reaction from either Buckingham Palace
or Kensington Palace which manages the
office of The Prince and Princess of
Wales but you do Wonder give them the
personal level of some of these
Revelations how long they can hold the
line of staying silent they won't want
to Fan the fuel the Flames of this Feud
any further but at the same time look if
we take for example the Oprah interview
and the Netflix docu series Harry made
accusations then without naming names
and this time he does he really doesn't
hold back and you know on the one hand
you can say well here is Harry wanting
to tell he his side of the story as he
puts it we know and we can see how much
he struggled losing his mother at such a
young age and struggling really with the
fact that William was more important his
older brother was the heir and he he was
the spur and yet at the same time you
have a prince with this hugely
privileged platform unable to deal with
the role the rules and the
responsibilities of Life inside the
royal family and the revelations are
still coming ITV have released a new
trailer for their interview to be aired
at the weekend and Harry describing that
kitchen fight with Prince William talks
about the Red Mist that he said he's had
over the years but he saw the same Red
Mist in William that day and the fact
that he said William looked at him and
he wanted
um as he puts it me to hit him back
Harry resisted at that point so we
haven't heard anything from the royal
family that might change because don't
forget the book isn't officially out
until Tuesday the palace will want to
read it very carefully and of course
Harry's got at least another four
television interviews to be aired before
then as well so there could be even
worse to come
indeed Laura this story will definitely
roll on for the next few days won't it
thanks very much indeed
well as you'd expect the Royals feature
heavily on this morning's front pages so
let's take you through a few of them put
your dukes up that's how the Daily Star
reports the story of Prince Harry's new
book with he and William pictured in
boxing gloves as the war of words
between them Escalades
according to the express there's now no
chance of Harry being reconciled with
his family because he's quote sold his
soul
the mirror features a picture from the
days when the princes were at school
together and good friends but his
headline reads it's all over now
Harry spills his secrets in devastating
Memoir that's on the front of the times
the eye sums the story up as the worst
crisis the UK monarchy has faced for 30
years
Ukraine has dismissed Russia's
unilateral order for a 36-hour ceasefire
as a trick President Putin had told his
troops to observe a truce from midday
today to Mark Orthodox Christmas but
Kiev says it won't be following sued
saying that Russia will only get a
cease-fire when it leaves Ukrainian
territory
now the Russians want to use Christmas
as a cover to stop the advance of our
guys in the donbass for a while and to
bring in equipment ammunition and
mobilize people closer to our positions
what will it result in just another
increase in their losses
well International correspondent Alex
Rossi joins me now from the Ukrainian
Capital Kiev so president zielinski Alex
giving short shrift to this offer of a
ceasefire from Russia
yeah that's right so Russia offered this
uh ceasefire yesterday it appears that
it's going to be simply a unilateral uh
ceasefire if indeed it can go ahead at
all which of course is extremely
questionable because you really need two
sides to abide by it remember the
fighting along those hundreds of uh
miles of the line of contact is
extremely ferocious and this war is
extremely uh bitter I don't think the
Kremlin really thought that the
ukrainians would ever really give this
much stock at all remember of course
that cities like Kiev have been under
attack now for many months so there is a
great deal of skepticism I think the
thing to look out for of course is will
there be attacks with cruise missiles uh
with drones now this ceasefire has
so-called ceasefire has been implemented
by the Russians that is something that
is in their gifts because remember
there's an asymmetry in this war when it
comes to that ukrainians are not
attacking Russian civilian
infrastructure inside Russia they're not
attacking civilians so you can do that
but I don't think it's going to change
anything on the ground in the Don bass
particularly with president zielinski
was talking about and the fighting the
artillery battles are still likely to go
on there now domestically for Vladimir
Putin he has a win either way with this
he can position himself as taking the
moral High grounds to his audience
inside Russia saying that you know this
war isn't a war of choice we have to
fight this war and look here we are
offering them a ceasefire on this very
special day it's Orthodox Christmas Eve
today Christmas day tomorrow and it's
being rejected by the ukrainians they're
that type of people so we need to carry
on fighting the other thing of course
that he's probably very worried about is
that Russia has had significant losses
of personnel over the last few weeks
according to the ukrainians in one hit a
few days ago they killed 400 Russian
soldiers now these are Russian soldiers
that have just been mobilized President
Putin has a severe Manpower shortage and
it's likely as we move further into the
new year that he's going to have to
mobilize again just to keep the war
going at the level that he is doing at
the moment so he does have a few
problems of course offering this
ceasefire he would have hoped would have
given him some breathing room which has
been reflected also by the Americans
they are saying that this again is just
hypocrisy it is a ruse President Biden
saying that he's doing it because he
needs oxygen the Russians are in a
trouble here and it looks as we go
further into this new year there's
questions about how they're going to get
out of that indeed Alex thanks very much
indeed
now here train passengers are looking at
yet another day of disruption with rail
workers starting another 48-hour strike
in its long-running dispute over paying
conditions in some areas they're going
to be no trains at all so let's get a
sense of the picture now Skies Aisha
zaheed is at Paddington Station for us
this morning so Aisha people are getting
used to these strikes now it's been such
a week of them what level of service can
people expect today and how soon might
this all be over
well we're currently on day four or five
of strike action when it comes to the
railways and about 20 of normal services
will be running and that's because it's
the rmt union this time round staging
their 48-hour walkout the second 48 hour
walkout of the week and yesterday we had
the drivers Union as left-taking strike
action as well so more disruption like
you said I think people are used to what
they should expect to see when the
strike action does take place so it has
been really quiet here but where
services are running they are limited uh
schedules are reduced uh trains taking
off later in the morning and then
Services ending earlier in the day
compared to usual as well as the message
from train operators really is so first
of all check if trains are running in
your area before you plan to head out
but also only to travel if it is
absolutely necessary and are we any
closer to seeing the union strike any
kind of deal while talks will be
resuming it's expected early next weeks
so far the unions have said that it's
been the government blocking any type of
negotiation and deal from being struck
that's something ministers have denied
but another move from the government
yesterday they confirmed new legislation
around strikes which would mean that
minimum levels of service would need to
be insured during strike action that
apply that will apply to various sectors
including the railways and it's
something that they we should expect to
see discussed in the Commons in the
coming weeks but that won't help for now
there is this significant disruption
over the course of the day today
tomorrow and then into Sunday as well
Aisha thanks very much indeed
so let's say good morning to Rob our
political correspondent hello to you Rob
and so I just was mentioning it there
the government has taken the step of
giving a few more details for its
anti-strike legislation that it wants to
bring in what what's included in it but
what kind of income pack could that have
on the various disputes that are going
on well it would mean that NHS staff
teaches firefighters rail workers as
well would have to provide a minimum
service level and it would mean that
employees that were asked to work under
that and didn't could be sacked it would
mean that unions that didn't comply with
those minimum service levels could be
sued as well so the government's very
much saying this is about protecting
lives protecting livelihoods there was
some concern during the last ambulance
strike about whether all major emergency
category call outs could be staffed
during it in reality clearly it's
another part of really the maneuvering
and the ongoing battle that's sort of
playing out between the governments and
unions I think though it does doesn't
necessarily go as far as some people
were expecting there had been a lot of
reporting that Richard sunac was
thinking about changing the rules around
ballot thresholds and things like that
or even saying that ambulance workers
weren't allowed to strike adding them to
the lists of people like soldiers and
police officers who are not allowed to
strike he hasn't gone that far some
reporting that might have been because
of concern that the whole package of
legislation could have been held up by
the Lords if he had as Aisha was saying
there though this won't do anything to
change what's going on at the moment and
the current strikes that are happening
today on the railways and also later
this month we'll get a walk out by NHS
workers as well and in terms of that
dispute that's going on between the
Royal College of Nursing and the
government overnight the Times newspaper
times radio has heard from the Royal
College of Nursing who have said that
they would be willing to accept a 10 pay
rise to call off these strikes
previously the demand had been 19 I
think what's going on here from the RCN
is they're trying to counter really this
attack from the government that what
they're asking for is unrealistic I
think in reality though the government's
line isn't going to change that they're
not reopening the 2022 pay deal they
said they will sit down and have talks
about the 2023 pay deal but at the
moment the two sides still look so far
apart that it's hard to see how there's
a path to these strikes in just under
two weeks being called off indeed um
okay Rob moment thanks very much indeed
so let's take a look now at some of
those other headlines and a research
into new cancer treatments including
personalized vaccines could be sped up
the government is due to sign a deal
with a pharmaceutical company a biontech
which worked with the covid vaccine it's
hope that similar
immunotherapies could be deployed
against cancer in the coming decades
after three days and 11 rounds of voting
the U.S House of Representatives still
doesn't have a speaker the Republican
Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy hasn't
been able to get enough votes from his
party which narrowly controls the
chamber one McCarthy critic even voted
for Donald Trump a symbolic but pointed
sign of deep divisions
Mexican security forces have recaptured
the son of the drug lord El Chapo a
video Guzman's arrest triggered
gunfights in the country's Northwest
where police say that members of his
cartel shot at commercial planes at the
airport the 32 year old was last
captured in 2019 but was released to
stop a wave of violent retribution his
father is serving a life sentence in the
U.S
the man accused of killing four students
in the U.S state of Idaho has appeared
in court charged with four counts of
first-degree murder Brian coburger was
extradited to the state after his arrest
more than 2 000 miles away in
Pennsylvania last week it comes as
authorities reveal that they found a
knife sheath with the 28 year old DNA on
it at the scene
do say whether still to come here on the
show as the Republicans struggled to
elect a new house Speaker I'll be joined
by former ambassador to the U.S Lord
Derek
neighbors Shadow Chief secretary to the
treasury Pat McFadden will be with me
just after eight
[Music]
it's claiming that they're suffering big
losses as a result of the rail strikes
I'll speak to the chief executive of UK
Hospitality Kate Nichols
now with the NHS coming under
unprecedented strain this winter nearly
half of parents say that they don't feel
confident about getting quick day-to-day
medical care for their children a Paul
by the website mums Ned also found that
a third were unable to get a GP
appointment for their child in the
previous three months
well I'm joined now by the chair of the
Royal College of gp's Professor Camilla
Hawthorne uh very good morning to you
thanks so much for talking to us first
perhaps it's useful for you to give us
an idea of the kind of pressures that
GPS are under give us a sense of what an
average gp's working day looks like
okay I think first of all I really
wanted to say how sad we are to see
these survey results because we want
parents to have confidence in the NHS
and in NHS services and certainly GPS
and their teams pull out all the stops
possible to see children to make sure
they get timely and appropriate care
so a GPS day nowadays
um is um unbelievably busy
um it's common for GPS to see between 40
and 60 patients in a day which is really
not sustainable and sometimes not very
safe I was talking to my brother-in-law
yesterday who was a GP in Farnham and by
tea time he'd already dealt with 140
patients which is way more than I've
ever heard before so it's a really
really busy pressurized atmosphere it
starts at about seven or eight in the
morning it can often go on till eight in
the evening GPS will then go home have a
quick bite to eat and then get onto
their laptops to do all the paperwork
that's accumulated as a result of seeing
all these patients so it is at the
moment we're working absolutely full
tilt now it isn't because GPS are not
seeing patients because they don't want
to they really do want to and it's a
source of enormous frustration for us to
feel that we're not able to do our job
in the way that we would like to and
that's because there just aren't enough
GPS due to years of underfunding
and poor workforce planning and in a way
the coveted pandemic followed by strep a
followed by influenza is just
highlighting the nature of the problem
so GPS are feeling stretched according
to this poll a large number of people
feel that they struggle to get an
appointment for their children so what's
the solution
well the solution really is to have a
bigger Workforce you know we need at
least 6 000 more GPS that's what the
government Manifesto said in 2019 to be
delivered by 2024 so they're way behind
on that because in fact the numbers of
GPS are actually dropping so we're now
about 700 short of where we were two
years ago we're not increasing in
numbers and a lot of that is due to
burnout and people leaving the
profession early and what we really need
is better retention strategies for GPS
to keep people in the job and working
seeing patients in the way that they
would like to do
well yes and in fact in the mum's net
poll 86 said that they blamed the
government for the crisis in the NHS do
you agree then
uh yes I think that it's been a number
of factors really
um you know you can't blame the
government for covid-19 or for strep a
but those have really just highlighted
the underlying uh shortage in Workforce
and we've been uh warning the government
about this for at least a decade
probably longer that numbers of GPS were
um were falling and that this was going
to become a crisis and also that in
order to run a functioning Health
Service you need a robust general
practice you need to have a good Primary
Care Service and there's very good
evidence from across the world that
countries that have a good functioning
Primary Care Service have a much
healthier population
we're seeing walkouts by nurses and
ambulance staff is there a mood amongst
GPS for industrial action do GPS want to
strike
no I don't think they do at the moment
um it's not really our function as a
Royal Medical College to comment on
terms and conditions of um of of work so
it's not really within our remit to
comment on this and we wouldn't normally
discuss it but um speaking anecdotally
I've not heard of a concerted move
amongst GPS wanting to go on strike at
the minute
however beyond the strikes amongst
nurses and ambulance workers do you
think it's likely that we could see more
widespread walkouts amongst other
healthcare workers
I think there is just so much pressure
um on Healthcare staff right across the
NHS and it's really important that Staff
feel able to do their job properly to
the standards that they're trained for
and under the right conditions and that
is really I think what is underlying a
lot of the dissent and discontent that
we have currently
and and I wonder if you have have a view
on the ongoing dispute with the nurses
uh we have seen reported this morning by
the Times newspaper that uh Pat Cullen
the the head of the RCN the the nurses
Union at saying that she might be
prepared to meet the government halfway
would look at an offer of around 10 even
though the nurses Union has asked for 19
originally what do you make of that and
do you feel that progress could be made
I really hope so I think no NHS worker
wants to strike it doesn't matter who or
what you are within the NHS resolution
is the best thing for everybody
concerned and of course particularly for
our patients it's not for us to get into
details of what this might look like I'm
afraid
um but I think whatever happens it's
absolutely essential that we all work
together to minimize the impact on
patient safety
well Professor Camilla Hawthorne a chair
of the Royal College of GPS we really
appreciate your time this morning thanks
so much for talking to us thank you
with us here on Sky News breakfast
coming up as Rishi sunak and secure
starmer set out their competing Visions
for the country we'll ask what the
future holds for British politics
[Music]
so it's been a big week in politics with
the Prime Minister Rishi sunak and the
labor leader Sakia stalma both
delivering their party's Visions for the
year ahead so let's take a look back
then shall we with the former labor
party advisor James Midway and former
aide to David Cameron Sarah Southern so
very good morning to both of you Sarah
Southern to you first of all two
speeches to kick off the year which
leader do you think did a better job at
laying out what he's all about
or certainly the leader that made it a
little bit more exciting was Kia stammer
I was delighted to see that his team had
obviously done a number of wreckies and
found somewhere exciting and interesting
to do the speech it was wonderful to see
it uh looking so interesting rather than
the kind of stayed boring background
that the Prime Minister opted for
five very clear
pledges of what he wants to do many of
which I think we would hope would happen
regardless you know let's hope that the
economy grows let's hope that NHS
waiting lists are reduced but it felt as
though kirstama really placed himself as
the change candidate that he's kind of
not weighed down by former Prime
Ministers and such like he can actually
present what he in a labor government
would want
well yes I mean do you agree with that
James Midway I mean both of them really
talked about change Richardson
Keen to make sure that he makes a clear
distinction with from the prime
ministers that have gone before him as
well who did it more successfully do you
think
well it was I mean Rishi sunak had a
kind of speech into halves he had to say
in the first bit um what he was going to
do about the mess that we're currently
in and he had to talk about it in a way
that didn't implicate himself or the
governments he's been a part of all the
party that's been in government for a
significant period of time so it's a
difficult job um the five pledges I mean
they don't actually add up to very much
inflation which he wants to halve by the
end of the year the bank of England
forecast say inflation is going to halve
Anyway by the end of the year economic
growth going up again well if the
government does nothing you kind of
anticipate that happening uh regardless
it doesn't add up to very much the
second half of the speech where he talks
about his vision
um centering on Innovation and some
elements of you know how we must have
strong communities I mean fine as far as
it goes frankly I think the the talk
about Innovation and the way he phrases
this is a little bit passy it's a bit
sort of you know 2000s Blair speak
really that soon like sometimes channels
so they're speech in two halves without
the two halves joining up together other
starmo did a better job of presenting a
kind of integrated vision of this and he
can do that because he's not been in
government so he has a critique of what
government's doing and I think some
interesting things to say below the
headlines about Labor's concerned to
present itself as not spending too much
about what he will do about the longer
term problems and the structural issues
so he had quite a lot of attack lines on
the Westminster system not just the
conservative party but the whole sets of
Institutions we have in Westminster that
labor says it's going to start trying to
reform with Devolution with the Gordon
Brown proposals with this Take Back
Control bill so really quite a contrast
in the two approaches sunk of course is
somewhat hampered by actually being
prime minister and things being in a
right Old State at the moment well yes
and Sarah I mean okay some similarities
there and some contrast to what extent
are we though seeing a coming together
onto the center ground of the two
candidates how different really are the
two different prospects
well I think that's very interesting
that we now do have two quite centered
around candidates and if you look at
where we were well three years ago
before
um starma came in we obviously had
Corbin and Johnson who were very much
towards the other extremes of the
parties so I think we are going to see
them coming to coming closer and closer
together but I think also as we're in
such a difficult time here in the UK at
the moment it's kind of less time for
kind of radical ideologies and more for
Solutions and helping people out and
making sure that people do have more
money in their pockets that they're able
to access the NHS more easily so I don't
think we're going to see people going to
the extremes anymore I think we are
going to see people coming swiftly
towards the center ground
well yes and Sarah Richie sunac has said
that the five pledges that we've talked
about were the people's priorities do
you think he has hit the nail on the
head there or do you think there are
people that are saying these aren't
actually our biggest concerns what about
the pressures on the Health Service what
about the strikes up and down the
country is that a problem for him do you
think
I think anyone going to work this week
who hasn't has either had to work from
home or has taken two hours to get to
work because the train strikes will
probably see the strikes very high up in
the same way anyone who's waiting for a
minor operation and that's been delayed
or whatever it may be may think you need
to sort the NHS out we've seen what's
happened with all of the delays in
people waiting for ambulances over the
Christmas period people will want that
to be sorted out I'm sure that that is
at the top of the priority list for the
health secretary going into 2023 but at
the end of the day the energy crisis the
cost of living crisis is what's going to
really hit people hard in the coming
months
his job's a lot easier in many ways
isn't it he's he's ahead in the polls
he's also not under pressure to deliver
immediately but how does that affect how
much he promises I mean it's going to be
some time before he could be in power so
how much do you say now and how much is
there a risk that any ideas you do put
out there could get stolen
well I think the look I mean customers
spent actually quite some time kind of
introducing himself I'm sure people
watching this program will be broadly
familiar with his personal story which
he touched on a bit yesterday uh by this
point and not so much time saying what
labor might actually do now that side to
change I think at Party Conference last
year with some big promises uh on
setting up a new publicly owned uh
renewable electricity generation company
the green transformation the large
amounts of investment going into that
and that was all repeated yesterday so
it's starting to set out a stall a bit
what was interesting about this speech I
thought was that it was less the policy
uh sort of elements there which is
mostly a repetition of things he said
already and more the framework of how he
wants us to think about what's going
wrong with the country which isn't just
the conservative party in power is a
problem and obviously he's going to say
this it's labor right they're going to
say that but also this sort of
institutional issues and I think he's
kind of right on this if you look at
just how bad uh the British economy is
doing relative to our nearest
competitors our peer economies in Europe
wherever it might might be we really are
in a very bad State at this point there
is a need for longer term bigger changes
and that's the kind of point I think
that storm is trying to get to and I
think we'll hear more from him over this
year about what those bigger structural
long-term changes that labor wants to
make might start to look like sunlight
doesn't have the same ability to talk
like this he can say vaguely at some
point in the future uh once I've cleaned
up this mess which incidentally I've had
no part in causing by the way uh where
things are going to be great with loads
of innovation and strong communities he
can't make the same deep structural uh
critique in the same way that starmer
has and I think if Sam gets a language
right around this that's potentially
quite an attractive and hard to
challenge offer for the next election at
the end of 2024 let's say
and very briefly I thought from both of
you um Sarah first of all we we heard
that Rishi sooner could rushed his
speech forward to try to be ahead of
kirst farmers how worried is he about
the competition how you know is how
concerned is he about this labor leader
I know this is just a sign that we're
very much on to general election footing
even if it is two years away it wouldn't
really sit well with the Prime Minister
that the leader of the opposition is
laying out his stall ahead of him I
remember in 2010 David Cameron gave a
speech I think on either New Year's Day
or the 2nd of January to make sure that
he got out there ahead of Gordon Brown
so I think it's not surprising that as
soon as Rishi sunlight got wind that KIA
Stamo was making his speech yesterday
that he went for the day before okay and
very briefly from you James what your
thoughts on that well look I think
Prince Harry is Trump both of them
that's what people are talking about
this morning and probably the
government's rather grateful that
kirstan has probably suffered more as a
result of this but you know politics is
like that sometimes these things turn up
and that's what's going to occupy
people's attention right now
that's that's the nature of news isn't
it well James Midway and Sarah at
Southern thanks very much indeed uh for
talking us through those speeches uh
really interesting to get your take on
it thank you
now the U.S House of Representatives has
adjourned after failing to elect a new
speaker for the 11th time now it's the
first time in a century that a nominee
hasn't been chosen on the first vote the
Republican party leader Kevin McCarthy
has failed in every round to secure the
218 votes needed to win so let's get
some reaction to that I'm joined Now by
former British ambassador to the U.S
Lord Derek
um very good morning to you thanks so
much for talking to us this morning so
three days 11 votes still no U.S House
speaker how's this all going to end do
you think
good question Anna um thank you for
inviting me as you said this is almost
unprecedented and I think it's more than
a century since something like this has
happened
there are Quincy standouts in the
Republican Party mostly from the far
right of the party who are refusing to
endorse Uh Kevin McCarthy and because
the Republicans have such a narrow
majority in the house that's enough to
mean you can't go to his 218 votes and
we've been through 11 uh now 11 rounds
and it's hard to see how this is going
to be resolved because uh they're not
shifting and there is no sign that
they're going to he's made the most
extraordinary concessions to them still
no sign they're going to shift there
isn't really an alternative candidate
out there because remember McCarthy gets
a supporter of almost 200 of the
Republicans in the house these 20 don't
seem to have an alternative candidate
certainly not one who command you know
majority support amongst the uh the
Republican party so I don't see where
this goes next McCarthy May uh may be
able to make some more concessions but
he's already conceded so much what more
can you do so it's um it's an
interesting question
well yes and presumably with concessions
come problems I mean if McCarthy does
manage to offer enough to convince the
doubters and he does become U.S speaker
does that affect the amount of power
that he would have absolutely I mean you
just said that some of the concessions
he's offered are places on the most
important committees to some of these
these hard right
um uh Republican candidate uh
Congressman but also the a tiny number
maybe only five of them could demand a
vote on the replacement of the speaker
so he is already
massively weaponed his own position
should he actually get the job uh and
it's hard to see how much further he can
go when he's off of these sort of things
what about Donald Trump's intervention
he's come out and said to those people
who don't want to back Kevin McCarthy
you should do it go ahead and do it what
difference might that make
well
the information so far is has made very
little difference because he is he has
said that and the the 20 yards were
refusing to back McCarthy are mostly uh
strong supporters of Donald Trump
um but what we're seeing actually is the
first manifestation of the struggle for
the future of the Republican party for
the silver Republican party
traditionally Tropical Party is the
party of blue taxes small government
free trade strong alliances overseas
um the Trump Republican parties took the
sort of culture wars and chaos and where
does it go in future there's lots of
signs that Trump's influence uh over
over the party is is winning and you
know Trump has done badly in the last
three elections in which he has been uh
been involved so you know who argue he
reduces the future but what is the
future of the broken part in this seen
that struggle start now
so that question being examined now and
meanwhile today is January the 6th so
it's two years since the attack on the
Capitol Building where's that left the
US do you think with reflection any
long-term effects do you think of what
happened then
first of all we need to see whether that
senate committee report
600 Old pages of it
um some really dumbing stuff about uh
the former president's influence over
and incitement of the attack on uh of
6th January on on the capital where that
goes there is still um it's for the
justice department but it's far from
impossible that criminal proceedings
against against the former president
will now be initiated we'll see we'll
see
um but second you know
this was an attack on American democracy
for a while it was on the edge remember
the rioters got quite close to the room
whether their vice president Mike Pence
was was hiding it was an extraordinary
and appalling event six people died and
it really put a question over over her
stability and solidity of American
democracy and I think you know American
democracy survived that and Will Survive
but the Republican Party really need to
have to think about about
where they stand on this because a
number of accounts including some of
those who are now who are now holding
out against Kevin McCarthy supported
that right uh one of them Marjorie
Taylor green said if she'd been in
charge the writers would have been armed
and they would have succeeded so there's
some pretty extreme views in Republican
party which they really need to
um to think about I don't think people
like that should be allowed to run for
election again
and I wonder since we have you here
whether I can get your views on another
topic that which is
um obsessing the news headlines and that
is the imminent release of Prince
Harry's book and the fact that it was um
apparently accidentally put into shops
in in Spain briefly one of the
revelations that's come out
um concerns his time in Afghanistan and
some military experts this morning
raising some concerns about security
after he revealed in this Memoir
um that he killed 25 Taliban fighters
um as a former National Security advisor
do you share those concerns
um slightly look uh you have to respect
um all of those who fought in
Afghanistan I went there a number of
times when I was an extra security
advisor it's a really tough environment
it was really dangerous War we lost more
than 500 British servicemen so it was um
you know
to express the respect and appreciate
all those who fought there
um uh personally if I've been advising
um the prince I would advise against the
kind of detail that he goes into there
um but you know it's out there now and
um uh you know I I believe it was a just
war and therefore what he has written
about how he justified to himself what
he was doing I can understand and
appreciate that but in terms of the
detail I personally wouldn't have gone
there but it's done now
and do you think now there's a greater
risk to his personal safety or to that
of his family
I'm not sure about that
um uh I mean you will have uh and we'll
continue to have
happy
um and I think that's right that he
should
um whether there's a greater risk
because of what he said I mean
I'm not sure I'm not sure you need to uh
to look into things and um and and you
know try and do a proper assessment of
that rather make a snap judgment and I'm
not sure actually the Taliban I think we
have enough problems themselves in
Afghanistan where they are proving to be
as expected appalling and repressive
rulers to worry about
um someone who's Living in America but
let's see
were you quite surprised to see how
candid he was about his time in
Afghanistan just personally
personally a little but you know
um it's a very candid book as we've all
uh all starting to realize from the
extracts that have been that have been
leaked but yes I was personally a bit
surprised but it's out so there we are
well Lord Kim Derek uh so good to talk
to you this morning thanks so much for
sharing your views on a range of
subjects this morning we really
appreciate your time thanks very much
thank you
let's take a quick look at what the
weather's doing shall we
well the mild and unsettled theme will
continue but today will bring a good
deal of fine weather it's a mostly dry
and clear start but Scotland is windy
and showery with severe Gales in the
north those showers will become more
scattered throughout the morning
coming up in the next hour on Sky News
breakfast we'll have plenty more
reaction to Prince Harry's new Memoir as
well as further strikes today we'll
Analyze That with Pat McFadden of Labor
[Music]